hey guys so today we're doing a
wonderful fitting with Diana hello
so this weekend is the SAG Awards that
I'm going to be I'm essentially going to
be the trophy girl for the Art Directors
Guild giving out the awards and I'm
pretty excited Jenna's gonna be my hot
date ooh I'm gonna have you guys help me
pick out a dress I believe Jenna's
probably doing the same thing mm-hmm
oh my gosh I Anna you always go
overboard like look at this oh my gosh
everything is so pretty Jess what's what
what's the problem here
well so this right here is supposed to
be here but we can't get it over my body
oh no big booty probs
like oh come on you can do it no isn't
can it will I cannot it will not go over
that oh all right
- I like it I like it I'm so upset that
I could no I wish I could have filmed uh
trying to get out of the stress but I
couldn't because there was there was
stuff flopping everywhere I mean this is
this is definitely princess so I like
this one I feel like it's a little too
dark
this dress is kind of crazy it's kind of
unlike anything that I've ever really
picked or worn because of all excuse me
I'm oh my that tan line though it looks
like I'm naked we think critics give
them a look what happens if I were the
purple one - this is classy classy
trophy lady love the Train god I'm gonna
fall no you are you're gonna have he'll
moly what a minute it's just gonna drag
look and it has a beautiful hand line
yeah I can see it
we'll have to deal - it's pretty
so I know I said only to let you guys
decide but I might have found the winner
already oh my god I wish I was filming
the conversation because it was a total
just like girl chat it was it was it was
a stereotypical what you would imagine
three girls in a room trying on dresses
with that battle I like it it's comfy
slip ha ha look at this clutch I love it
this is so awesome the only problem
phone wolf it holy crap is this great
whatever you laughter those are you the
Diamonds yet oh sorry y'all we're gonna
look like for a couple look Kardashians
look all you got you got nothing on
these hoes these whoo basic hoes all
about that bass so yeah using like a
lover big dang big oh yeah phone camera
thank you
alright guys so the fitting is done
thank you so much to Hannah I love
getting to work with you it's always so
amazing so let me know what dress you
guys think that I should wear I think I
might have already chosen one so we'll
see I'm so excited for tomorrow it
should be a good time Tyler Oakley will
also be there so stay tuned for
tomorrow's vlog from the SAG Awards it's
gonna be awesome
John are you ready to turn up I am okay
yay turn down for what